let me read this post that Michelle
Obama put up back in college I was one
of the few black students on my campus
and I was proud of getting into such a
respected school but still I sometimes
wondered if people thought I got there
because of affirmative action today my
heart breaks for any young person out
there who's wondering what their future
holds and what kind of chances will be
open to them Michelle Obama as ever sees
these things through the race lens now
he herself is an exceptionally
privileged person she she is married to
one of the most privileged people in the
world
their children when applying for college
I think they've already done that but
should they be regarded as right black
applicants to Harvard or wherever or
should they be regarded as being
highly privileged and therefore marked
down